and joining me here in studio directly
across from me is chris wallace the
anchor of fox news sunday you can follow
that show at fox news sunday on twitter
check your local listings on your local
fox station you can watch replays on fnc
he's also a best-selling author his new
book that he has here in studio with us
and if you're watching on the fox nation
live stream you can see the cover of it
or you will when it comes to him and the
title of that book is countdown bin
laden the untold story of the
247-day hunt to bring the mastermind of
911
to justice and chris it is such a
pleasure to see you in person for the
first time
in 18 months or so i was going to say a
year and a half i i i thought i'd gotten
out of jail but no i'm back with you so
i'm so sorry
countdown bin laden how's it doing it's
just a totally compelling read and i
think it's fair to say the definitive
account of how we got bin laden well
thank you for that uh
it's doing great it's the number two for
the second week in a row the number two
book in the new york times bestseller
list both hardcover and ebook um you
know which is nice uh but i'm really
proud of the book and i'm very pleased
by the reception it's gotten it's a
history thriller
you know you know how it ends but the
people i get a lot of emails from people
at two o'clock in the morning saying i
couldn't put it down darn you i just
finished it uh and and
you know that that the last hundred
pages they were just on the edge of
their seat because they wanted to see
what happened next there are surprises
things that have not been said before
told before people who haven't talked
before um
it's a good book it you know it just is
i'm proud of it countdown bin laden by
chris wallace our guest available for
sale right now chris i want to play a
couple sound bites for you the president
finally deigned to answer some questions
today it'd been a while
and he was asked about the border
this alleged whipping quote-unquote
incident of course came up and he
decided to kind of lean into it and go
nuclear to a certain extent here he is
in cut seven
it was horrible what to see as you saw
to see people treat it like they did
horses really running over people being
strapped it's outrageous i promise you
those people will pay
they will be an investigation underway
now and there will be consequences
there will be consequences it's an
embarrassment but it's beyond an
embarrassment it's dangerous it's wrong
it sends the wrong message around the
world or sends the wrong message at home
it's simply not who we are
the vice president kamala harris was on
the view a little bit of a bumpy start
to that show today we'll play that audio
later she echoed this line cut 19.
i've been very clear about the images
that you and i both saw of those law
enforcement officials on horses i i i
was outraged by it
i it was horrible and um and
deeply troubling there's been now an
investigation that is being conducted
which i fully support and there needs to
be consequence and accountability uh the
human beings should not be treated that
way and as we all know it also evoked
images
of some of the worst moments of our
history
where that kind of behavior has been
used against
the indigenous people of our country has
been used against african americans
during times of slavery and um so i'm
glad to know that that ali mayor is the
secretary of the department of homeland
security is taking it very seriously
and moments ago the aforementioned
mayorkas was at the white house at the
podium and talking about systemic racism
and how horrified he was by all of this
and chris i feel like i'm
losing my mind because i've watched the
videos i've looked at the images the
photographer who took the famous
photograph has now come out and said we
didn't see any whipping the photo is
being misconstrued border patrol says
there was no whipping there were no
whips
but it has this talking point has just
been willed into existence that border
patrol was out there whipping haitian
illegal immigrants
and the president is denouncing it you
know from the very highest level the
biggest bully pulpit in the world
have you seen any evidence that people
were whipped no uh
but i have seen the guy the border
patrol using their horses to intimidate
and and and
push back people i
let me
go with my big point and then i'll get
to the to the whipping in in the in the
first place when i was hearing the clip
of the president he was talking about
this is embarrassing
uh
it's uh wrong and it sends the wrong
signal to the world
i was thinking he really should be
saying that about our immigration policy
and the fact that fifteen thousand
people came across this dam into del rio
and then were had to spend
days more than a week in squalor under
this bridge i mean to me that is the
real shame here is our immigration
policy and that it allows people to come
over it doesn't just stop them
and that's what i think the real focus
ought to be on
yes the the the horse story the the
border patrol cbp on horseback
uh has become a story i happen to think
it's a it's bad forget the whipping for
a second and and i i understand that's
one of the allegations and there doesn't
seem to be true and the president
shouldn't have talked about strapping as
he did because that's another
word for whipping i don't think that
the border patrol they ought to be able
to find a way to keep people from coming
across the border
build a fence a wall maybe yeah i was
going to say build a fence build a wall
have a have some kind of a gate so they
can't walk across that dam
over the
rio grande into del rio i don't know
that i think the idea of guys on
horseback stopping migrants from coming
by rushing out them bull rushing them
with the horses forget whether there
were whips or not i don't think that's
right and either i'll find that i find
that offensive really yes i mean police
police departments use horses and crowd
control in the united states against
citizens but this is this is a different
thing this is people coming across the
border illegally
i understand i'm not saying they should
be allowed to cross the border i'm
saying there ought to be a less
offensive way to do it like putting up
barriers or a wall i that's all i'm
saying
i think the idea and you know i don't
think that you usually see horses in
crowd control
racing running at these people uh the
way that they were in in in american
cities the way they were at the border
with these haitians yeah i think
we can get into the specifics of crowd
control and police tactics and i happen
to think that's missing the point i do
too good and i think it's actually the
goal of the administration for us to
miss the point which is the crisis so
let's not let's focus on the real news i
agree it's just i think to me
during the last president he was
criticized a lot for making things up
and not saying things that were in
alignment with actual facts and i think
why i'm so bothered about the whipping
stuff even though i'm taking the bait
from the administration is that it's
just not true but they keep saying it
i agree i agree about the whipping but i
don't think that that lets the border
patrol off the hook because i think the
whole use of horses was wrong okay
that's the point i'm making but again i
think that we're missing the point which
is
the the real problem here is that it was
allowed to happen because of the
negligence of the biden border policy i
mean here's the problem i have with with
biden talking about a more humane policy
so they say we're going to have a more
humane policy we're going to and we're
going to roll back remain in mexico and
the result of rolling back remain in
mexico is that it entices it
it says to people trying to come across
illegally and illegally is a big deal
that it's okay to come across the border
and if you have to wait for weeks or
months or years in some cases to have
your your immigration hearing you'll be
able to do it from the comfort of being
in the united states i think it actually
would be more humane to say to them no
don't don't don't come over don't be
huddle under the bridge stay in mexico
or don't come up at all because i think
this half door open policy is creating a
lot of problems
that that a stricter policy wouldn't and
we have
1.5 million known border encounters this
fiscal year and counting so far plus
hundreds of thousands of known godaways
what's happening the policy is failing
the whip stuff is
a a sideshow right i think they stop
talking
the policy is a mess i agree i think
that's why they're happy to repeat the
lie about whipping is because you and i
will sit here i'm talking about it you
will sit here i'm not i'm not talking
about the weapon but the president is
the vice president
we've covered it let's move on to the
policy and i think the real problem is
the policy the policy is wrong and and
you know i i just watched some of my
orcas maybe this is why i'm spun up
about it because he said that we
inherited a broken system and we got to
fix it they're not fixing it and and he
talks about well comprehensive
immigration reform we all know there's
not going to be comprehensive
immigration reform i agree there should
be but there isn't going to be just as a
matter of political reality so find
measures that you can use that will
alleviate the system and part of it is
as an american i'm offended at this open
door that's allowing people to come in
15 000 wouldn't you think somewhere it
turns out that in del rio he said this
for the first time since september 9th
they've had 30 000 people come across
the border wouldn't you think somewhere
between a hundred or a thousand and
thirty thousand you'd have said okay
let's stop it and what they inherited
obviously not a perfect system by any
stretch but the numbers weren't anywhere
close to this in the last administration
so just say oh well you know this is a
broken process so what can we do
that doesn't hack it
do you have anyone from the biden white
house on fox news sunday this weekend
because i saw some people last weekend
saying they offered no one from the
national security team after the
admission of the the drone strike that
killed seven children
are they offering up people we don't
know uh you know we have asked for uh
mr secretary mayorkas and we're
interested to see whether they're gonna
make them available or not we do know
we're going to have an exclusive
interview with the governor of texas
greg abbott so we'll discover discuss
the issue at length we'll also have a
report from on the ground at the border
um and we're hoping to have somebody
from the administration
that we can ask some of these very good
questions about i you know the thing
about
i'm not going to contradict myself about
the whipping oh chris they won't even
discuss i mean somebody asked well what
is it that you think they did wrong and
my orcus wouldn't even say what they did
wrong i happen to think the horses was
wrong the whipping seems to have but
they should at least have an answer to
that when they're saying they're
horrified they're treating it like a
crime against humanity they also didn't
make it clear
in my orchestra part of the news
conference i saw as to how many of these
people from del rio have actually been
released into the united states to wait
for processing yes they're supposed to
see an immigration judge but that can as
i say take years
over on capitol hill just you know steps
from where we sit right now democrat
leaders are having a real whale of a
time wrangling votes for a number of
different issues you've got the
reconciliation package you've got the
debt ceiling you've got this bipartisan
infrastructure bill
they're putting out statements they're
making noises about progress but i'm not
sure if the progress is is concrete or
tangible yet how do you see this playing
out or is this truly
fluid well it's it's absolutely fluid
there's no question about it
they definitely are not going to have a
government shutdown the the democrats
are the controlling party the governing
party they control both houses as well
as the white house there's not a chance
that they're going to have a government
shutdown on friday morning uh debt
ceiling
they're not going to go into default
somehow that'll get settled the the big
question are the
1.2 trillion dollar infrastructure bill
and the spending bill which is now at
three and a half trillion
i suspect it'll be less
you know i it's absolutely fluid and i
only say this because as a political
realist i don't see how the democrats
with control can't come up with a
compromise it may be a lot less than
bernie sanders want a lot more than joe
manchin one there's got to be some
number between one and a half trillion
and three and a half trillion which is
where they both are that they could both
hold their nose and agree to because it
seems to me you put the democrats in
charge and they can't pass their own
president's agenda that is a catastrophe
a political catastrophe pelosi feels
like she can't let that happen and she's
generally pretty good at whipping the
votes a different kind of whipping yeah
chris we got to use that i feel like so
you're too young to get the reference
but i'm sure some of your listeners were
in groucho marx it used to be a magic
word and when you said the magic word a
duck would come down with the magic word
that obviously today it's whipping last
question very briefly the least
important question you'll get all week
we had a poll here on the show and we
had jesse waters weigh in and our
colleague jimmy fail away in and then we
posted it on on twitter as well
of the male correspondents here at fox
news the question was who has the best
hair it was peter ducey was mad finn it
was bill malugion
malugion won
thousands of people voted malujin won by
a 17-point margin chris i have to ask
you did the people get it right in your
mind say it again it was peter ducey
malugion and matt finn
no malugen i i agree with volunteering
you know i sometimes i look at maluga
and i think if i had looked like him
that would have been no stopping me i
might have been a success in this
business well you are a success because
you've got a huge you could have been
somebody and you've got a number two
best-selling book in the country let's
make it number one countdown bin laden
countdown bin laden by chris wallace my
guest will be watching fox news sunday
this sunday i'll be on the panel looking
forward to it chris that that's a
readings booster right there let's hope
it's the guy benson show we'll be right
back
you